that have been made since 2011. the
others have been paid back either to
deutsche bank or to other parties that
had ended up lending it
yeah sorry that was a simple question
that i made very complicated
isn't there a lot of irony here that the
germans are supposed to be these
prudence savers
and uh
uh you know
i've always
felt this and all of a sudden deutsche
bank which is their national bank
is wanting
money this way to trump and
and others i mean
does this money come from those prudent
german savers that are that's being
alone
well deutsche bank is most of the money
it's lending is actually money that it's
borrowed from big international
investors uh through
issuing debt or selling stock things
like that so it's not the german savers
who are subsidizing the trump loans but
the interesting the real irony of that
to me is that the whole reason deutsche
bank felt it was necessary and important
to get into
doing the wild and crazy stuff it did on
wall street and with characters like
trump is that it turns out that being
the bank to a bunch of savers and people
who don't really want to borrow money is
not lucrative and so the bank at the in
the 80s and 90s was watching as its
rivals in america and in london
were just
minting money on all sorts of crazy wall
street activities and on people's
just burning desire to get into debt
people in institutions burning desires
to get into debt and so
deutsche bank serving a primarily german
clientele
the germans did not want to go into debt
they'd been you know they're scarred by
their own historical legacies and uh
and so deutsche bank went was really
trying to boost its profitability and
attract international investors and the
way to do that was to make money by
lending by getting other people more in
debt and so it turned its sights toward
uh really all over the world but um
including an america where it found
people like trump and can i just also
say before i forget this is completely
unrelated to your question but uh
it's not just trump that they were doing
business with and trump is obviously the
most famous kind of marquee client they
had and obviously it's generating lots
of headlines but i mean this is a bank
that was so desperate to get in bed with
anyone who could that it would just it
would it was really just open for
business with the worst of the worst of
american capitalism and jeffrey epstein
i think is the kind of clearest example
of that jeffrey epstein obviously kind
of lied to everyone and said he was a
billionaire and was this wonderful
financier blah blah blah and but by by
2012 2013 after he'd been convicted of
sex crimes people realized that he was
kind of full of it and that he was you
know morally reprehensible and so he
started getting kicked out of his banks
and the final bank to kick him out was
jp morgan which finally washed its hands
of epstein in at the end of 2012 early
2013 and epstein who at this point was
you know had a lot of money that he had
somehow from some people and was still
trying to keep up this facade of being
this international kind of businessman
didn't have anywhere to go and he
probably would have had to shut down his
dirty little operation were it not for a
certain bank that came and decided even
when every other bank had cut him off
from the financial system it was willing
to get in bed with him and that bank you
will not be surprised to hear was
deutsche bank and deutsche bank
continued to do business with epstein
up until the time of his arrest last
summer and that was even after
multiple employees in the compliance
division and elsewhere in the bank
raised concerns not only about the
ethics and morality of doing someone who
is not only a convicted sex criminal but
also was well known to be having done a
lot
more bad stuff than what he'd been
criminally charged with but it was also
that they were seeing signs internally
of him laundering money and
possibly bribery and things like that
and yet the bank
once again overruled those concerns and
continued doing business with epstein
because it seemed lucrative to do so
yeah this is a bad bank
yeah i was wondering uh you know first
what is sort of the net worth of
deutsche bank right now and then what is
the
roughly the total amount of fines and